well take me back to the moment then
when arielle announced that you guys
were the winners of love island what was
going through your head the winners of
love island 2021
are
olivia and corey
[Applause]
it's crazy because we just like
obviously left the villa so we're still
processing this but you know
when she said our names i was like
yeah
jaw on the floor speechless
and
like
we're so grateful it validates that
everything the way we moved in the villa
and you know following our hearts and
really like doing the hard things
opening up being vulnerable it paid off
and like if anything like
um it's just taught both of us a lot and
uh yeah
yeah i would say the same thing too you
know like i was completely shocked as
well because like from day one
i thought will and keir are gonna win
like they instantly like clicked up and
they're like official boyfriend and
girlfriend and like granted we're not
that but
i didn't know if that had anything to do
with this so i was like all right people
are gonna see like they're actually
girlfriend boyfriend and they live five
minutes away from each other and they're
real
so i was thinking that they were gonna
win to be honest so when they said
olivia's name first like right after
that i like blacked out like oh my gosh
oh my god
well i gotta tell you you know in years
past it's been pretty clear like that
who would win love island you know it's
been traditionally i feel like a couple
who literally have been together since
the beginning you guys have a way more
interesting journey it took a minute
before you guys found each other you
know uh so when you did finally pair up
and couple up what was it like where did
things begin to change for you two
um i think the biggest
shift was casamore
um you know we obviously everything's
not shown it's an hour you know we are
living breathing
everything love island so we're together
every moment so we had a really strong
friendship and
um you know i would even talk about
other guys to him like i mean we were
very open with each other yeah and he
would give the most genuine advice and i
think that cost them more i realized
like what i thought i wanted looked
different than what i was expecting and
possibly i was like
you know what i've come this far
still single i rather leave singles my
head up high
and confess myself and my feelings to
this man and if he denies me i'll take
an l but it worked out for me i guess it
really did grow
it really did do you feel like having
that friendship as a foundation helped
oh yeah yeah i mean i've never had that
before in any relationship ever so for
me it was very refreshing and like there
was no like we weren't trying to impress
each other ever and there's no pressure
at all because
you know we're the same other than
yeah i would say too like that
definitely
helped me a lot is because obviously we
weren't coupled up from the beginning
and not until the very end so
yeah we didn't have that pressure of
being in a couple and like trying to
impress each other day in and day out
like it was super authentic and
we got to see each other grow as
individuals first
and then that's when we like
just gravitated towards each other so i
would rather have it that way 100 versus
coupling up from day one yeah
um do you guys feel closer than ever now
like where do things stand and how they
feel now
yeah things are good okay
i'm excited just to be like on the
outside with him and have our alone time
because let me tell you
sleeping in a bed next to i don't know
five to ten couples right
after a while and you know everyone have
ideas on how to maneuver around the
villa
you only got to hide away twice
i know we're like so spoiled
i was gonna say that's more probably
that's actually two times more than some
people in that house
i know
um for it yeah exactly you guys made the
most of it for sure corey what are you
excited to explore about your
relationship out in the real world now
that the cameras have turned off
yeah just um we kind of got a taste of
it too we went on a helicopter date
which was really amazing and
you know even just the car ride to it
we're just sitting in the car just like
listening to music and just vibing out
and that that was kind of like a taste
of what it would be like in the real
world and then
we get on this adventure i've never been
on a helicopter in my life so one this
is just to me automatically the most
amazing thing ever and then
for her she was scared at first but she
did it because she knew how excited i
was so i think that ultimately like made
me attracted to her even more but um
yeah i'm just ready to go on literally
any type of adventure and
just have all this adrenaline and
all everything rushed to us i choose you
it's always venue
and this is just the beginning
[Music]
what the freak we did
[Music]
okay apologies if this puts you guys on
the spot but what are you calling each
other are you saying boyfriend and
girlfriend have you put a label on what
this is or could be
we haven't okay uh like i said i think
that
we're just like vibing out roll with the
punches there's literally no pressure
and we're very clear where we stand but
for us like it is real
so i don't want to rush something as
well as he doesn't want to rush
something and it not work out i'd rather
have the moment that you know we decide
to make it official be special memorable
and be real
kind of like
kind of like our journey in the village
you know if we would have came in day
one and
try to like rush in
put that title let's couple it up and um
i feel like if we did that now with the
girlfriend boyfriend thing it would
definitely add that some sort of
pressure you know but um honestly i'm
loving where we're at like
i feel like that's just a title we do
everything we have now left each other's
side since
literally day one pretty much like we
live and
see everything that we do so
yeah i'm just excited for what the
future holds in i look forward to 100
you guys are doing it right and it also
feels genuine and real you know if you
were quick to kind of be like hey we're
boyfriend and girlfriend it's almost
because you won the the show you know
and not because you're trying to pursue
something real
yeah exactly yeah i want to know have
all spoken to cash what was her reaction
to you winning
oh my god yeah we based on her last
night you did
stoked i mean two of them so cash
obviously is my best friend
as well as corey's and
she's just like what the freak hey
i was like yes
i mean she before she left the villa she
did a little you know hype girl speech
as i was trying to be strong the whole
time i'm not shooting it too
um
and she's like girl
keep being you you got this you and
corey my besties and yeah
i love it i was gonna say you guys look
like you've bonded so closely with so
many people on this
on the season what do you what will you
remember the most uh through this
experience
i hope i remember everything to be
honest yeah
a lot but um i would say
getting for me personally getting ready
doing your hair makeup with the girls in
the girls room
you know just having like playful banter
with them you know learning a lot like
i've learned so much i mean
i thought i knew a lot
i didn't know anything like about
relationships or about yourself
about just myself as well as how people
move and you know i've learned to be
more empathetic um
with people and that's something i'm
forever grateful for because you never
know people are going through yeah i
would say the biggest thing i'll
probably remember is just just like all
the goofy times like with the guys in
the downstairs dressing room like we're
just dancing just like smacking each
other with pillows like wrestling
like literally not a care in the world
and we're just having a time of our
lives and then
also too like when we always eat lunch
all the girls would be in the kitchen
like just dancing and twerking and
singing and stuff and and the guys like
we're in the background just like hyping
them up so like those are memories i'm
never gonna forget like at all so it's
awesome it's like the like the ultimate
adult slumber party
all right i want to know how you guys
spending this 100k together i know you
talked a lot about traveling i think
egypt was thrown out there have you guys
started to make plans on how to spend
this money
new york on friday yeah you run in new
york friday okay that's exciting and
then i'm going to virginia beach after
that so
honestly i think thank you for getting
that we won money because we're so in
the moment and like we're just like it's
a breath of fresh air to just have our
own space you know
um together so
i don't know i mean we're just gonna
vibe out yes okay make spontaneous
decisions definitely travel though yeah
traveling for sure i love it do you guys
have any regrets looking back at your
time on the show is there anything that
you would have done differently
no
yeah
i wouldn't say either maybe like in the
moment i was like damn i'm making the
right decision but just reminiscing and
reflecting over the whole entire
experience
everything played out i think in the
best way possible like even the down
times i think those needed to happen for
for me to learn what i needed to learn
and then i'm sure olivia feels the same
way so yeah there's absolutely nothing
i'll change about my whole entire dream
do you guys have any plans to go back
and watch the whole season in its
entirety and if so is there anything
you're nervous for the other person to
see
um
i look i think we will watch it i'm
gonna give a beat maybe yeah because
it's a lot and i'm like i don't want to
relive those emotions right now
right
but um no not i'm not nervous for um
anything about him or anything like that
yeah same here you know i've told her
everything i've done and i think it
helped out a lot too is
literally like the whole entire first
half of the show we didn't have any
expectations of each other so there was
no pressure to
even like they cost up more like we both
went into that single so
there was nothing that we could have
done that would have upset each other
and we're both super honest with each
other so no matter how we're feeling
about each other or someone else like
we've always been open in that aspect as
well